avoue stéphane pour guillon 2012
[Musique]
françois hollande a passé son week-end à
la lanterne une résidence réservée au
premier ministre mais que nicolas
sarkozy s'était approprié la lanterne
est doté d'un tennis d'une piscine et
d'une des plus belles caves de la
république je veux être un président
normal qui passe ses week-ends à
versailles à deux pas de vélizy des
pauvres un président capable de savourer
un romanée conti après un tennis les
deux pieds dans une piscine mais qui est
aussi capable de rentrer à l'elysée en
stop les intérêts de l'état l'exigent un
président normal
[Applaudissements]
le directeur d'une maison de retraite
accusé de pédophilie
ça c'est qu'on sait qu'on quand tu aimes
te taper des enfants travailler dans une
maison de vieux c'est qu'on
imaginait un gérontophile travaillant
dans une maternelle la vie est parfois
mal fait
[Applaudissements]
l'espagne ne voulait pas que sa
candidate gagne le concours de
l'eurovision en cas de succès l'espagne
rongé par la crise aurait dû organiser
l'événement l'année prochaine ah c'est
ça c'est ça
je me demandais pourquoi on avait choisi
anggun c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
l'année prochaine fois demandé à
jennifer
[Musique]
là des fans de jenifer
était en baisse
sclérose en plaques la france
particulièrement exposées à enfin un
truc qui marche bien en france
arnaud montebourg le ministre du
redressement productif voulait avoir ses
bureaux cinquième étage de bercy une
bataille acharnée perdu par arnaud qui a
dû se contenter du 3e étage
je voulais le 5e et quand
je le voulais
pour redresser l'économie de la france
de la gomme il est essentiel d'avoir une
vue aérienne
pouvoir regarder d'en haut les français
les manants et légumes
afin de résoudre leurs problèmes je veux
dominé thierry ardisson goûter l'air et
sommaires et faire agrandir toutes les
fenêtres de mon ministère pour pouvoir y
passer la tête
je m'aime je suis capable de jouir en
regardant meurent frais dans une glace
[Applaudissements]
un article très émouvant dans le jdd sur
le blues des battues françois fillon
pour la première fois depuis cinq ans
s'est retrouvé seul frédéric mitterrand
à
1 re pressent scooter et
nicolas sarkozy a accouru sans gardes du
corps
excusez moi thierry
il nous manque un c'est faux comme une
marque
cécile duflot s'est rendu au conseil des
ministres
un rer
avant ils se déplaçaient en voiture avec
chauffeur et escorte et bloqué des
quartiers entiers
comment voulez vous que je bosse
après s'être rendu à bruxelles en train
françois hollande est revenu en voiture
je veux
rentrer en voiture et faire le clash est
totale car avec 50 points vous pouvez
offrir un repas aux restos du coeur je
veux celui qui en faisant le plat permet
d'aider les plus démunis si je gagne un
service à thé je l'offrirai à quelqu'un
qui n'en a pas je veux être le président
qui cumule le plus de points chez total
enfin on termine avec un petit peu
d'animation grâce à dsk mercier merci à
lui
dans la sphère du carlton de lille le
parquet ouvre une enquête pour viol en
réunion
viol en réunion qu'est ce que c'est
jean regnaud d'un viol qui s'organise
côté plusieurs avoir beaucoup d'ennemis
un emploi du temps très précis aide
ponctuelle
dans confondre avec le viol pendant une
réunion
à de mégots lanyon vous emmerdez de
saison compliqué votre secrétaire est à
vos côtés et vous la violer
il faut qu un pas confondre non plus
être le viol à la réunion
violent effectués dans le département
d'outre-mer
océan indien
un viol humide très chaud
mais moi ce que je préfère finalement
enfin une alliée c'est le duo de
nafissatou
beaucoup plus simple une carte d'hôtel
une porte qu'on laisse entrouverte je
dois jouer
you fuck
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu